here's a shocking update from the daily
wire Carly Russell the 25 year old
nursing student who claimed that she was
kidnapped earlier this month while
allegedly checking on a toddler on the
side of the road in Alabama admitted to
law enforcement that she fabricated her
entire story I can't believe it Hoover
Police Chief Nick durzis said that
investigators are still going to meet
with Anthony Anthony because they have
more to discuss in the case including
the possibility that criminal charges
will be filed it was fake the the story
that was the most obvious fake story of
all time turns out to be fake the thing
we all knew was fake is fake that's the
big headline